you talked about the body language of
leaning in and you use it as sort of a
metaphor in terms of gauging people's
interest so when you would see a scene
that maybe you didn't quote lean in how
would you go back and tell the actors to
maybe regroup and try it again what was
your style it's a really great question
I i think when we don't lean in there's
something that's tripping us up and not
allowing us to be fully honest whether
it's the actors or me the sets the
camera position the dialogue so we try
to my job is to go in there with the the
broom and sweep out the sort of
obstacles that are keeping us from being
honest beautiful enjoy your night thank
you